how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Avengers in game has officially hit
theaters worldwide millions of people
have already seen the movie and are
raving about how amazing it was and
after seeing Avengers and game many of
those people have some questions so in
this video I'll explain the ending of
Avengers endgame obviously a huge
warning I'm going to be talking about
spoilers in this video I'm going to be
talking about major events of the movie
including how it ends so if you have not
seen Avengers in game and you do not
want anything spoiled here is your last
chance to click away alright if you're
still with me let's talk about that
ending as we suspected the Avengers go
back in time collect all of the Infinity
stones make an Infinity Gauntlet and
perform a snap of their own bringing
everybody that died thanks to Thanos has
snapped back to life this included not
only people but all living creatures who
died thanks to Thanos a snap however
right before the snap 2014 nebula and
2014 Thanos captured the present nebula
so if a nose comes up with a plan and
sends back to pass 2014 nebula to the
future and replace of the future nebula
and then immediately after the snap 2014
nebula opened the time portal to bring
Thanos from 2014 and his army into the
present time the present nebula also
comes through with him they immediately
destroyed all of the Avengers compound
and then we saw the most amazing battle
of the MCU Captain America Iron Man and
Thor against Thanos one of the biggest
parts of the MCU and entire movie was
Captain America lifting Thor's hammer
Mjolnir how was Captain America able to
lift mule near simple he was worthy he
almost lifted it in Avengers age of
Ultron moving it just a little bit the
most popular theory going around right
now is that he could not lift it in
Avengers age of Ultron because he had
not yet told Tony that he knew Bucky
killed his parents
however after Captain America Civil War
he told Tony Stark that he knew Bucky
killed his parents so now in Avengers
endgame his conscience is clean which
made him worthy to be able to lift mule
near but many people were also wondering
how could he shoot lightning Thor is the
god of thunder which is why he can shoot
lightning but why did Captain America
wielding Mjolnir let him shoot lightning
well it's simple it's because of its
enchantment the enchantment reads
whosoever holds this hammer if he be
worthy shall possess the power of Thor
so since Captain America was worthy
enough to lift mule near he got the
power of Thor which of course is
lightning the three of them continue to
fight Thanos right until they're about
to be defeated but right when they were
about to be defeated we saw many portals
opening up in the background and through
those portals came every single hero
that exists in the MCU both the ones who
have died from the snap and have now
been brought back to life and those who
survived every single hero in the MCU we
then saw the greatest battle of the MC
use history all of the heroes in the MCU
versus Thanos and his army during the
battle there are many different reunions
including the heartbreaking one between
Tony Stark and Peter Parker and during
this reunion we learned that those who
were victim to the snap remember being
snapped kind of they remember turning to
dust as we hear Peter Parker tell Tony
do you remember when we were in space
and I got all dusty proving that Peter
Parker remembers turning to dust which
leads us to believe that everybody else
would remember turning to dust as well
however those that were dusted did not
go anywhere after they didn't go into
the soul stone or into soul world they
simply died as Peter doesn't remember
anything saying that I must have passed
out because I woke up and you were gone
so those that were dusted remember
turning to dust but don't know anything
else because they simply ceased to exist
what was a brief second to those that
were dusted was actually five years and
as those that were dusted arose back
from the dead dr. strange was waiting
there for them dr. strange foresaw this
future he knew that he would die but he
knew that everybody would get brought
back to life therefore he knew where he
needed to be and he knew that he needed
to bring all of the heroes into this
final battle to help the Avengers take
on Thanos and that he did the Infinity
Gauntlet with the Infinity stones that
the Avengers made makes its way around
the battlefield the avengers tried to
return it to the past but eventually it
winds up in the hands of Thanos it all
comes down at the end to a battle
between fan oohs and Iron Man when
Thanos gets the Infinity Gauntlet with
all of the Infinity stones he looks at
dr. strange in which Doctor Strange puts
up his finger symbolizing one
referring back to when dr. strange went
forward in time and saw over 14 million
different scenarios and which the
Avengers only won one of those so Doctor
Strange putting up his finger telling
Tony one means that he's telling him
that this is the one scenario where the
Avengers wins and Tony immediately knows
what it means it means that he has to be
the one to grab the Infinity stones and
perform the snap in which he does and
snaps away Fano says army including fan
OHS and sadly he dies doing the snap but
he saves the universe they have a
funeral for him in which every single
hero is there for and there's even a
teenage boy there which many people do
not recognize this is Harley keiner the
little boy from Iron Man 3 we also
learned that Professor Hulk tried to
bring back Natasha with his snap when he
brought everybody back to life however
he couldn't so it appears that Hawkeye
was right when he said that the stone
keeper said he can't bring them back to
life you cannot bring back the people
who are sacrificed to obtain the soul
stone with the soul stone so Natasha and
Gamora are dead at least Gamora from the
present timeline but now 2014 Gamora
exists in the present timeline however
she ran away after the battle which is
why we see star-lord searching for her
at the end of the movie and of course we
all noticed that he now has a buddy Thor
Thor has left the reign of Asgard to
Valkyrie and is now going with the
guardians of the galaxy on their
adventures calling them the as guardians
of the galaxy which by the way is a
comic series it isn't with the guardians
of the galaxy and Thor however it is a
comic so at the end of course professor
Hope promised the ancient one that he
would bring back each stone to each
individual point in time where they took
them from Captain America took this
assignment onto himself
professor Hulk says that he will go back
to these points in time return the
stones and then come back it should be
five seconds in the present time however
after five seconds professor Holt tries
to bring him back but is unsuccessful
professor Hulk Falcon and Bucky then
turned and realized there's an old man
sitting on a bench nearby this of course
is Captain America captain returned all
of the Infinity stones to their point in
time but then went back in time before
he went into the ice and that is the
timeline in which he stayed he lives his
life out through that timeline finally
getting his
dance with Peggy Carter who he ends up
marrying he lives until he ends up in
the present time waiting for that exact
moment when he goes back to return the
stones he then passes the mantle of
Captain America to Falcon giving him his
Captain America shield and that is it
for the ending of Avengers endgame
there's a lot that is set up for the
future of the MCU with the ending of
Avengers and game which I'll talk about
in a different video but let me know
what you all think of Avengers endgame
what did you think of the ending and was
it all that you wanted it to be let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and a reminder about my giveaway
I'm giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark fan of
painting by globe I bow I'll put the
link to his other artwork in the
description down below if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof - your desperation to save the
universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it and all it
took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby